foreign
there's a brand new tourist attraction
in America that's all the rage but you
might want to get your hepatitis shot
first a local San Francisco guide is
offering a thirty dollar Doom Loop
walking tour of the city's most
crime-ridden spots letting people get a
good whiff of the liberal policies that
have turned America's wealthiest city
into a cesspool of open-air drug markets
and homeless encampments and while San
Francis Decay could be a boon to certain
tourism it's a death sentence to
retailers the owner of gum San Francisco
a place that I used to frequent as
little Greg is warning that they might
close for good after 166 years of doing
business
our business is a business that people
love and people want to come into San
Francisco want to come visit a store but
if you if you can't get around and when
you're trying to walk the streets you
step over
needles in human waste and often bodies
on the streets it makes it an unworkable
business environment and if that wasn't
enough human misery on display how about
Philly where businesses are now being
forced to set up booby traps like hidden
sprinklers to ward off drug addicts who
keep scaring customers of former drug
dealer turned activists comparing the
situation in Philly to a zombie movie
illegal pass to do whatever you want I
mean you see the chaos that's going
around you're going to see people blood
running down their arm needles in their
neck needle in their arm piping their
mouth
everything goes out here you're
literally dealing with chemical warfare
you know that's what's happening you see
the people falling apart uh limbs
falling off you've seen Duffy when we
was down there his arm it looks like a
zombie movement and speaking of drug
addiction the problem is only getting
worse Americans say fentanyl poisonings
are now the biggest public health risk
the country faces surging to number one
followed by obesity gun violence and
cancer so Charlie I want to go to you
first I think that we have to pay uh the
Biden Administration a compliment they
created new jobs with the Doom Loop
tours
these jobs would not have happened if it
wasn't for his leadership that's that's
really finding the Silver Lining Greg
yes it is very impressive thank you but
you do have to sort of give a nod to
American Ingenuity I mean you know
America Americans have always or I guess
people of all Stripes have always loved
they love horror movies they love freak
shows and that's what this is it's a
it's a modern day freak Show circus
freak Show and um and and it's also it
goes to why Democrats are so successful
talking about climate change is that all
of the the terrifying uh stuff that they
promote on their climate change agenda
is it's it's such a great movie
everybody wants to go see the horror
movie but the idea that you would sit
here and say well it's really not it's
it's really not as dramatic as they're
saying that no one's gonna go see that
movie nobody wants to see the movie that
oh no it's all natural but um but no the
the larger problem here and obviously
it's a it's a huge problem it's a
complex problem and it's a horrifying
problem uh you have so many families uh
of all socioeconomic uh background all
parts of the country who are affected by
this and it's horrifying there's a
limited amount of things that the
government can do to uh tackle this but
everything thing that the government can
do such as closing the Border or
allowing a thriving economy or
Prosecuting drug convictions the by the
Administration has completely failed to
do and uh you know when you talk to
people who have recovered from drug
addiction especially with opioids the
number of them who say that getting
arrested and going to jail was what
turned me around
ought to be a lesson for us to about
where to go forward from here you know
uh judge you look at these store owners
in Philly setting up booby traps it's
kind of funny but you know if anything
goes awry they're the ones that go to
jail doesn't it remind you Greg of the
there was a guy who was took a hose to
some homeless people in front of his
business and I think he got arrested for
something or charged with something look
I I was a Narcotics judge and I was also
a D.A and I created and helped create
the drug courts in Westchester County
look you need the leverage you need the
stick they're not going to go into
treatment unless they're faced with jail
time and a lot of them would rather
rather go to jail than go to treatment
so
um we had something going for us when we
had the big stick and The Leverage what
has happened now is we have so
normalized drug abuse and drug addiction
that uh we have created these um uh safe
injection sites and vending machines and
with needles and all kinds of uh laws
that literally protect these people and
allow them to do this in front of
residences and businesses but in front
of your house Greg if you want to put a
three foot uh fence that you know you'll
get charged and and fined for doing that
but they can do that all over and
Destroy things and drugs are more
dangerous than ever now if ever there
were a time to at least consider the
criminal justice system as leverage it's
now because a little fentanyl is going
to kill you and let's not let fauci off
the hook all of this a lot of this
happened because of the school lock
workouts and the and the lockdowns in
homes and the highest overdose rate in
this country was in 2022 and that was
because people couldn't go to treatment
they couldn't have meetings and we're in
a bad place so we've got to figure out
like San Diego did it's real easy to
clean this stuff up you pass laws you
enforce laws and then people like the
guy from gum Zone have to stand there
and say we can't live like this there is
an intentional destruction of America
and it should stop and it can stop
speaking of covid this is interesting
Dana uh everything was shut down
basically except for liquor stores
marijuana dispensaries because they were
considered essential Services now if
they'd shut them down you would have had
moonshine which is what you're seeing
right now in our streets we're having
moonshine fentanyl because there's no
access to Safe fentanyl so they make
their own and then everybody dies so I
think logically you could make the
conclusion that if you actually made
safe legal drugs available you you would
probably see less overdoses less of
these crazy people on the street yep I I
do think there's Merit to that I just
don't know what the experiment you're
like Portland tried it that was
decriminalization not legalization right
so I I don't know I would love to see
like could we just get one test area
who's going to volunteer to be the test
I volunteer where Charlie Lives
fentanyl comparing fentanyl to Moonshine
moonshine is healthy it's there's
nothing it's really good okay I
apologize I had no idea and it's not
dangerous it doesn't come from China
it's not true it's really delicious so
what the judge was saying about covid
and 2022 the what did happen what else
happened then in 20 21 and 2022 the
border is wide open so then all the
opioids are coming all the fentanyl is
coming across and now you have the one
pill can kill situation with um in
California 20 of the deaths uh were ages
18 to 25 I went down this list of
Florida Pennsylvania Ohio Georgia it's
all the same like all the statistics so
today Victor Davis Hansen he's he did a
interview I haven't watched an interview
yet I was just reading about it where he
was talking about the fall of the
Byzantine and the Roman Empires and what
happened and I was just thinking about
how you just went to Italy a lot of
people we know have gone to Europe this
year because one of the reasons you go
is not just the food but it's to
experience the most beautiful monuments
and the architecture and the tremendous
civilization progress that was made over
those years and what are we doing
We are tearing down our own historic art
now
something they don't deserve to be out
there but do you destroy them or do you
put them all in a park somewhere
um we are letting our citizens lie in
their own extra commitment remember the
other day when you said people the young
women going to Pilates on Sixth Avenue
I'm not a young woman anymore but I was
going to Pilates today every single
block there was a man right lying in his
own excrement you have to basically you
cannot breathe through your nose from
here to Columbus you can smell from the
car it is horrendous and we are letting
people do that so I guess I kudos to the
entrepreneurs in San Francisco were
trying to figure out a way to make
duminate out of Doom yeah you know
Jessica it seems that your party has
turned the American dream into a
narcotic one what do you have to say for
all the destruction that your party has
Unleashed on what was once the greatest
country that ever was
as it's slowly and well rather quickly
descends into chaos headline Greg
Gutfeld doesn't think America is the
greatest country
I don't right out of your own mouth
I thought this is devastating I've
spoken about it a lot San Francisco is a
really important city to me I was just
there a few weeks ago
um and there are parts of it that I used
to hang out in that you just don't go
anymore and you're certainly I wasn't
bringing the baby down there pushing
Cleo around to see the sights and that's
really heartbreaking
um and it's happening in a lot of cities
this isn't something that is new you
don't get a decline at this level in
just a couple of years and I understand
that there has always been democratic
government there I think it has
accelerated from the effects of covid
but you do see a dichotomy within the
Democratic party in terms of how
officials will talk about it and I think
that London breed has not done as good
of a job in doing that she was late to
the game saying now she's added an extra
200 police officers but she was
resistant to acknowledging a lot of the
problems that were in front of everybody
and I've said it before and I'll say it
again these people who are complaining
are not Republicans in waiting they are
not turning into to voters for the other
side they are Democrats demanding a
better quality of life especially for
your tax dollars which are enormous in
cities like that one thing that the
owner of Gump said that I thought was
really important said that one of the
ways that we can help with this is that
companies need to demand that people go
back to work because if high-end workers
are now coming back into the city they
will be forced to clean up in a way that
you don't have to right now because the
buildings are just empty right right so
you can have squatting you can have
streets full of homeless people but if
you have folks that are earning six
figures and walking past they're not
going to be stepping over people to do
that I thought that that was really
interesting and smart to a point about
legalizing drugs though that is part of
why these safe injection sites are
important that it is better if somebody
is still the illegal drug that's the
problem
I understand that and should note also
that the fentanyl seizures are up
astronomically so 300 in San Diego which
you called out as a great example the
DEA announced
it's not a perfect solution but it can
be part of it and they have that's been
proven out before that safe injection
sites do help people because at least
you're not putting a dirty needle into
your arm and they can make counselors
available there
if the counselor doesn't have any drugs
on them they won't listen to him
well maybe one does oh there you go all
right you can offer them jail instead
they'll clean up fast
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else